ladies and gentlemen i've got an itchy
eyeball for some reason deal with it i'm
infected
guys this is the episode we've been
waiting for marvel's what if zombies
being brought into the what-if universe
i'm super duper excited for this uh if
you'd have enjoyed our reaction really
love if you could go ahead and hit that
like button helps us out of the
algorithm in more ways than you realize
while you're at it subscribe click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction is up you know things
like youtubers say yeah yeah yeah yeah
also full-length watch alongs where you
stick up with the time coder over at our
patreon page and over there we cover
many shows with the same tier you get
the option for both reaction highlights
and watch alongs included almost done
with avatar the last hair battery lastly
gotta thank pratham jindal for editing
down these highlights for us you are a
good good man would never ever put a
bullet to the head for you man i just
let you chomp right into me that's what
i tell all my friends
[Music]
i wonder if the zombie rules
here will be the same as they are
in the comic oh yeah
magneto and galactus are going to show
up and say characters i said rules
like star wars
exactly the human hiding within the hulk
fell from the stars to warn humanity of
imminent danger but the world he found
was not one he recognized okay going
from infinity war
all right then this is coming hello
anyone got any clothes
oh god
oh [ __ ]
it's like i am a legend
hear me and rejoice
come on come on
you are about to die at the hands of the
children
here we go
oh boy are you guys scrooge
wait what are you guys
[Laughter]
oh
no
seems like
overkill where are you guys
oh [ __ ] i can't believe it
oh
what now
oh
oh cool who are you
all that's left
just your friendly neighborhood
spiderman oh yeah well then what the
hell happened to the neighborhood huh
i hope we see spider-man in that cape
janet van dyne contracted a quantum
virus that corrupted her brain
oh
[Music]
that
oh
[Music]
the entire pacific northwest was
infected oh god ironically it was the
avengers heroism that sealed humanity's
fate on my mark out
oh
[Music]
zombie viruses pass through saliva so
the less skin you're showing the less
there is to bite
zombies are attracted to the smell of
human flesh the sneak attack
how about we skip the shower and grab
the body spray
oh
you eulogies
[Laughter]
my king went missing with the avengers
weeks ago
how neat
another survivor camp claims to have
made progress on a cure it's camp lehigh
in new jersey shields first base of
operations i thought you were an uber
driver no no i'm a personal chauffeur
there's a difference
[Music]
zombie kill of the week do you guys just
not have horror movies in wakanda we
don't need them we have american reality
shows ooh
[Music]
we're getting more juice train please be
working for teddy no it's not working i
love how they have kurt here that's so
funny to me
that falcon yeah
what if batman showed up
just uh birds oh
wasn't here
the last mentor is gone oh it's hawkeye
they fly now
damn they turn so fast
wow
yeah they do turn fast
come on buddy how many trains have you
pulled
sorry happy
[Music]
blanche
should be sad but i'm not let's go
[Music]
he's pulling a train like spider-man 2.
disengage the break on my mark
where's your peter tingle heck yeah okay
[Music]
i'm rooting for curtin hope to wind up
together we're all here
now we did it destination camp lehigh
sharon oh it's gotta be cap oh no i
think you've had enough cap
yeah i could chew this all day
nice
[Applause]
i guess this is the end of the line the
end of the line
[Music]
and he's got the shield now
hey i'm covered in sharon the kid has
hand sanitizer
slight nod to the thanos yeah no really
i think you're in trouble
oh
she's been like the best i know how do
you stay so upbeat
after everything in practice i guess my
mom dad uncle ben mr stark
but um aunt may says that if we don't
keep smiling when they can't then we
might as well just be gone too bad news
team the drain is run out to fuel how
far away are we from camp lehigh well on
the bright side we are at least closer
than we were
we're going to have to walk through that
[Laughter]
but you can make it over them
i might as well go out fixing the mess i
started you didn't start this your mom
and dad did
i started this but you are gonna finish
it you should have thought about the
zombie apocalypse every possible outcome
hope
damn wow
i hope she doesn't turn into a zombie
yeah
well she's in giant mode
then it becomes attack on titan
[Music]
peter it's not for me okay
[Music]
john goodman zombie
oh why aren't they climbing the fence
huh
oh god oh
we must be careful baba yoga nears
[Laughter]
the beach known to lurk in shadows of
sacred burial grounds spider boy come on
vision hey
the mind stone it emits a sub frequency
that is not to their liking could that
mean the infection is some kind of
encephalopathy brain stuff precisely
brainstorming
experiment to see if targeted exposure
might reverse their condition were you
successful ta-da
see for yourself
hey they did it yeah you know i need to
get this thing motorized
i've lost weight thank you for noticing
but don't worry i'm not gonna let it go
to my head
i'll canvas the base see if i can find
his transport sergeant barnes you will
not find
what you're looking for
uh oh
yeah
this is a good idea
according to these security logs we're
not the first to respond to vision
signal more survivors well then where
are they
what no vision
stop
oh no
oh
i really do wish you hadn't found us
vision what the hell is this place a
trap
he's been keeping him alive to feed his
zombie bride that goth chick i knew it i
was picking up vibes her name is wanda
yeah
i can assure you my actions though
unsavory were nevertheless born of logic
you lured innocent people to their
deaths all in the name of love
love sucks
what i have done so you should have no
problem submitting to human justice
you have awakened her
she hasn't eaten
in days oh [ __ ] oh god no no
move out of the way buddy
oh my god cool
[Music]
we need your help get us out of here
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no
okay my king
wakanda forever
there's a quad jet in the hangar you're
not coming i must atone for what i have
done but i cannot bring myself to leave
her
my dude
whoa
great
it worked guys
[Music]
oh
man
[Music]
run why even try bucky yeah dude what
are you gonna do with that gun
[Music]
oh
no
zombie hulk
nice safe big guy
i think i can buy you guys some time dr
banner no we are not leaving i just i i
really i don't think i can lose another
friend today so
avenge us
doesn't anybody here watch horror movies
oh damn it happened it happened
oh
[Music]
she gave her life so we could get the
cure that's twice she saved me huh
come on zombie movie's gotta be a bleak
ass ending
this is the resident evil ending right
here that is not the end they are still
with us as long as we do not forget them
and once we get this to wakanda
we're gonna save the world oh wakanda's
yep darkest of times humans will give
all to save their planet even if it
might bring an end to the universe
[ __ ] that's cool
what a tease that is
what is what is we should be dicks and
put that in the thumbnail yes
and i even put our faces just zoom in on
on on that
what would zombie thanos be snapping for
he probably have more like a double the
universe come back to
right there's one thing i want to check
the cast names of the list
oh josh keat that's so funny all right
because okay josh keaton versus
spider-man and spectacular spider-man
but here he's voicing steve rogers and
captain america
i mean i thought the guy played
spider-man hudson tames did a pretty
good job uh but i was like is that i
don't think it is but um just wanted to
double check that that would have been
pretty neat if they actually ended up
doing that but uh yeah sounds like for
the most part most of the people here
they they played themselves awesome
good to see that good to see that
and oh it was an unexpected surprise
there with t'challa which i think they
do that and i think in marvel zombies
that they do that i believe it's hank
pym though who's uh keeping t'challa
alive and is feeding off of him
uh little by little uh yeah but that was
like straight out of the actual comic
there's some little differences in terms
of the powers and stuff i like how with
the marvel zombies they still kept them
with they they still have the abilities
they're not just zombies you know but i
remember there's like some type of other
rule there where they you know after a
certain period of time after feeding
they kind of go back to their normal
selves they have like a constant hunger
and then if they're deprived of
anything to eat eventually they'll just
kind of stop being hungry yeah because i
remember it but then as but as time goes
back on then they go back to being
zombified or something like that
it's been a long time but either way um
yeah no i thought that was a fun episode
and i thought for disney plus they did a
really good job
at knowing how to do zombie gore without
going overboard where you're reaching
r-rated territory
i mean you know it's like
i i had to tamper my expectations with
this episode because
seeing marvel zombies in the trailer was
the thing that was like oh my god i'm so
excited for that
and then you know before filming this it
was like all right
let's dial it back now let's like it
overhyped because i could easily put too
much expectation
on what i would want out of this episode
just for that especially with the fact
that it's like it's marvel zombies so
i'm like i really wanted to go full
horror and then i wanted to go really
gory and i was like okay now let's just
set your mind to they're not going to do
any of that not at all yeah and so i
actually thought this better right in
the middle of what i actually thought
they would deliver
for uh a disney plus adaptation of
marvel zombies so they they took more of
the horror comedy route here where it
never got too horrific it never got
scary i would say
um and then with the gore they they did
a little bit more than i actually
thought they would end up doing uh which
was a pleasant surprise there was some
decent amount of head lopping and blood
gushing it's all black gooey stuff so
they don't go like red and they don't
make it like horrific to stare at but
they're a few pretty creative kills too
yeah especially when hope re-enlarges
inside of sharon yeah it's pretty icky
yeah there were some gross ones that
they managed to get away with or even
like falcon getting sliced right down
the middle
so i enjoyed that aspect of it for for
what they did would i like them to go
full on horror
uh to the point was because like yeah
they kept they managed to
for the most most of the episode i feel
like
balance it with
that
levity that comedy where it still felt
like a fun animated show
um where i i would have wanted them to
like really double down on the tension
of it all but they're having fun with an
alternate version of so like it is that
thing where i already prepped myself for
don't expect that
you know i could easily impose what i
wanted them to do on it so instead i
just got to go in here
uh taking what i
what i got and for the most part i
enjoyed it i thought it was fun yeah
it's a really fun episode i think just
in the immediate sense and for the
i'm curious to see how it'll hold up on
like a repeat viewing because part of it
for me is yeah that immediate novelty of
with you know the likenesses of our mcu
iterations of these heroes we're getting
to see an iteration of marvel zombies
come to like you know for me that's just
like it's an easy sell
and uh yeah for the most part i thought
the episode was fun like i like the
ensemble that they had together and i
liked the amend that they made from
again what i remember of the marvel
zombies comic is like they all talk and
stuff and they have just this insatiable
hunger and i like that here you know
they are zombies but who have that sort
of george romero kind of like oh yeah
they have their old
lives sort of in the dna of how they
move and act and they have their powers
but it's not quite a hundred percent
like oh they're lucid characters um and
yeah i'm a little torn on this episode
like i had a lot of fun watching it and
i think there is a lot of fun humor
about it
sometimes i wish some of like the meadow
like it's haven't you guys seen a horror
movie kind of commentary maybe
went further or did a little more than
that partly because i know that they are
working against you know it's not going
to be the you know crazy zombie
bloodbath that a lot of people probably
immediately think of and immediately
want and yeah i can't really hold it
against this episode not to be that but
i also yeah i wish they bridged that gap
a little more with maybe some like
crazier bit of context yeah or um yeah
maybe a better focus on the intensity
versus the humor not that i didn't find
it fun i think that i think it was a
really fun episode and that's kind of
the best thing i could say about it sort
of yeah i mean it's it's not really
tense
which uh was probably the like if you're
not gonna go full on horror because it's
like that again this is another what if
episode that i i think does uh detract a
little bit due to its run time due to
the fact of how short it is that some
stuff just doesn't
take the vision and wanda moment like i
love the choice of what they did there
with vision is keeping wanda alive wanda
feeding off t'challa
and then you know wanda being the
powerful being she is
and being zombified you know she's just
gonna be this monster who you have to
deal with like i love the choice of that
but i felt it was kind of moving a
little too fast uh from you know the
revelation of what vision has done and
why he's doing it to vision making a
different choice then
have being like you know what you're
right i need to break out of here i need
to kill myself you know like all those
things that happened it was move
it's like a 40-minute episode or
45-minute episode it obviously would
have just taken its time a little bit
more to settle in
with the mood of it all and really
dealing with you know what vision has
done
and uh yeah it just
it was just moving too
some stuff just moves too quick for the
more emotional beats or the more
tension-filled beats you know like
whenever i thought we were going to go
there it would kind of get it was
actually the thing that would happen was
that some people say about marvel movies
where we get you know a moment that
could be committed to the tension when
we get undercut by a joke a joke by
humor or something like that so sorry it
started feeling this weird blend to me
of like a pg-13 kid's animated movie he
was a little bit of the vibe i was
getting i had it so it was just it's
strange you know
uh where i i
obviously would have wanted them to go
all out to the point where
it's it's that thing where
like i i don't know if i i honestly
don't know if i'm i'm even disappointed
by
that idea that they didn't fully go all
out i wish they went or not
well i'm just saying i didn't know if
i'm fully disappointed only because i
really tampered my expectations prior to
watching this yeah
i guess for me if if if what that made
me think of is like i wish this episode
maybe went all out on something because
i don't really feel like it went all out
seemed like they had to be safe yeah on
any one particular thing i feel like you
don't necessarily have to go yeah all
out on gore you know you could go i mean
you know like
and again these aren't even about
adhering very strictly to the mcu or the
comic book stories but like there's a
lot of like twisted lore in that
original you know run of of
comics or whatever and so i felt like
you know
for what this was it was like okay hope
all right janet she goes to the quantum
realm she gets this infection she bites
hank he comes back and the zombie
outbreak and then that's kind of it and
they're gonna kinda and fix it yeah you
know and it's just it's like a very
simple story with a lot of like really
cool uh moments and a lot of like really
on uh like you know a lot of good
effective jumps it's the plot of a
zombie movie essentially
crammed into 30 minutes yeah yeah yeah
and it's like you find vision who you
think is like oh the heroics say oh no
there's actually something sinister
happening here that's a twisted form of
love like they're playing on all
everything here is
that like like i said i love all the
choices yeah i think every choice is so
cool it's just more of the execution of
the beats and and letting the scenes
kind of simmer a little more because to
be honest with you i think the doctor
strange episode actually felt more
harrowing and and more bleak yeah
absolutely and zombie apocalypse
episode i really really did which to be
fair though to on another note to be
fair
um
my recollection of the marvel zombie
thing which i didn't read all of it i
didn't i didn't look through all of it
and i had to kind of like refresh my
brain on some stuff earlier um
is that it that is a little campy all
right i don't think it's like the best
thing marvelous or like producing
there's a comic that itself is pretty
campy it's violent it's very violent but
it's it's not it's pretty cheesy
yeah yeah i wouldn't say it's like an
arc it's a novelty that is a lot of fun
to behold yeah it is uh but i i don't
think it's like the a great comic
personally uh
you can pick and choose if you want and
and not be mad about you yeah yeah uh
but for what they did here you know i
like where they chose to do the what if
scenario infinity war um starting from
there i like mark ruffalo's voiceover
performance here more than i did in
episode three i thought he uh had a lot
of fun i thought all the voice actors
were really good i even thought like
sebastian's dancing
he seemed a bit off to me in the first
episode yeah i know not everyone shares
that opinion which is fine
a lot of habit or [ __ ] opinion you
got uh
but uh yeah i
i thought he did really good here yeah
honestly the spider-man like the guy
played spider-man i thought he did a
really great i thought a great job too
yeah like i didn't make me miss tom
holland or wish tom holland was i mean
of course it'd be nice if it was tom
holland uh but it didn't make me miss
him he was a good match without making
me think about that and i thought that
actually funny enough with spider-man i
thought they really made him feel like
spider-man like
he
he felt like the most brought to life in
here
in terms of of like not i'm not saying
that they don't do that with the other
characters but for spider-man i i
thought they
they really brought the spirit of
spider-man alive whenever we were with
spider-man like that that exchange that
he has with hope
he feels like the most complete
character of this whole episode yeah
yeah that's my that's that's my point is
that i i thought they'd flushed him out
really well
uh like i did like bruce banner a lot i
thought yeah you know paul rudd's voice
work here as ant-man was
was i thought they were going to go all
out like the marvel zombie con like put
his head on something
but they did not they kept his futurama
style yeah yeah oh she made that i was
thinking two missed opportunity jokes
was that and and now you got uh michonne
just back right right back in the adr
studio doing walking dead just with the
wakandan accent oh yeah that's true oh i
totally didn't even put that correlation
together like three quarters way through
i was like oh damn this is like
every day for tonight
yeah
oh that's so true that's a great point i
did not even uh connect those dots there
which it was cool to have her like i
like i did like cuz you know like you
have so many
potential characters to choose from and
i liked which ones they had as zombies
and which ones they had as the survivors
i liked that it was sort of a random you
even got curt in there you got like a
kind of random mixture of supers and
people with elevated or just helpful
abilities i mean i could spend forever
going on about what i think they could
have done with a longer episode yeah
like to be completely frank
um
like i could write
the whole anthology's worth of what else
you could have done well i mean right
down to like bucky and
and you know what you know what like
pulls me out it like to something that
even on justice episodes on merits not
something of just what i would want
bucky one could argue is you know like
he's living in the zombie world he's a
trained soldier so he's just
made himself even more cold
uh to endure this right that's one way
of looking at it
uh but the moment when after sharon
turns
and i always doesn't seem to really give
a [ __ ] doesn't really acknowledge that
at all they make a joke about like
pushing her away and then or even having
some type of
emotional like when they come into
contact with the zombie versions of
these people they know
there doesn't ever seem to be and it's
it's just it's a classic zombie thing to
do i think of you know like oh no you
know why'd you [ __ ] no i can't kill
steve yeah even in zombie form yeah it
was like cool to see uh you know
zombie cat brought to live zombie iron
man brought to life
uh but you know it's like the most
reaction moments that happened i thought
were with like bruce banner when when
they first appear yeah and he's like
what what no what are you guys doing oh
my god
like that stuff was a lot of fun and i
and i like what they did with
you know um
because an infinity war that running bit
about how hulk's not coming out yeah and
then here
they uh let him come out like he saves
him with the first bite yeah and then
allows them to be a hero when they're
trying to escape in the quinjet i
thought was a really nice moment too
yeah
um
yeah i thought like
messing with that familiarity from
infinity war was was really neat
chadwick bozeman did another fantastic
job again and as opposed to playing
t'challa before now he's black panther
this time around
ah
such a
i like the ending it's a bleak ending
predictable ending except for thanos
part with the glove yeah what's he
snapping you're right it's a good
question is he snapping too is he
snapping away half of the zombie
population so that there will be more
humans to go around or is he just going
to snap more humans or is his brain
functional enough to snap anything
coherent at all i mean he's yeah cause
because sometimes the zombies seemed
like they were a hundred percent
coherent and exactly able to do the
ability and then you got someone like
hawkeye who's a little bit like the dude
away my bad the longer you're a zombie
the more you know brain dexterity you
build and the more of your old life you
get baby hawk i was just turned recently
so he's still learning yeah
to get it back
it's weird it's like i think it is a
really fun episode and there's like a
lot of moments i really liked and
there's a lot of like there's tons of
things throughout this episode that are
just like the the eas like it's the
easiest thing to have be fun about this
show but it is always fun is just the
whimsy of going oh it's this character
in zombie motors you know like the yeah
just the fun twists or horror movie
twists on each character in each
situation
it's just it's like i thought the scenes
could have had
some uh somehow i felt like there was
it fell short of conflict on a lot of
missed opportunities for a conflict
on everybody like it just felt like it
had an emotional toll on every character
and i don't feel like what you brought
up with bucky it's like they i feel like
and again i feel it's i don't want it to
be just the what they ought to or could
have done review but but you can't help
but notice it yeah because then i'm
thinking like
you could have you could have made that
kind of the thing for everybody is like
maybe uh uh you know okoye finds
t'challa in that situation with vision
maybe peter has to face down tony like
make it be that all yeah these zombies
are like really emotionally resonant to
each person not just oh we're all
avengers in it yeah it sucks that you're
a zombie well it was it was surprisingly
feeling light hearted in
many of the scenes that weren't
involving
like just killing the zombie yeah it's
like there seemed to be a missing toll
on the emotional weight yeah of a lot of
this that like would come in segments
like hope taking the blame
because i've only seen ant-man in the
wasp once i'm like oh yeah that's right
yeah she's looking for mama
so
yeah like hope taking the blame for that
hope dying
hopes
willing to like
you know go into giant mode and
sacrifice herself when she's already
dying so you know like that or like the
choice of like more of what they did
with kind of wanda and vision like i
love that choice it's so twisted yeah
it's twisted and it's within character
and
it's um you know it's like you're
like to me i'm like vish vision had that
was such a
that's usually what you give to like a
human character and vision i'm like no
you actually did like the most human
thing
yeah that
ahead of a lot of these people you know
because you are in your own way above
all of this anyway yeah because yeah and
that's a great twist too because at
first you're like oh god is he some kind
of like involved zombie oh no he's just
grief stricken again yeah you know and
and doing desperate things for love yeah
which is a neat flip off of coming off
of wanda vision where she was wanting to
keep vision alive yeah absolutely even
though he was dead so it's neat flip
it's another resonant thing rather than
just like oh a neat
happenstance but yeah i could kind of go
like scene by scene and go yeah but it
for
but that's the thing though is um
it's it's it's a matter of expectation
and uh
like of course there's that part of me
that is disappointed
but
i tampered myself
before going in so i'm like no it's
about what i expected at this point you
know what's funny is when we got to the
end credits and it was just those empty
rooms and those just slides of of
different settings and the art i was
like i wish the episode had more of this
because it is just kind of chilling to
look at all these familiar avengers and
spots run down and and you know you know
zombified and so yeah i was like it's
weird i wish
they'd just put some of this air into
the episode
yeah because uh
i don't know they kind of like they they
did drop the whole like he sh
banner shows up yeah about thanos yeah
and then he doesn't even like bring it
back up yeah when i'm like bigger do you
know you got like this
this is this world problem which i get
why you're so focused on the immediacy
of this and these are thanos's boys who
just greeted but the other part of me is
also like
um
but thanos is a universe threat yeah
this is a
and so i think that would have helped
better bookend that
uh that that beat with thanos being
there with the infinity gauntlet i think
that would if if there was a reminder of
that situation that was part of bruce's
story for the episode yeah had anything
to do with that initial piece because
yeah because then it just feels like oh
that's a fun connective bit that doesn't
really lead to much yeah yeah i think it
would have bookended it a little
stronger yeah absolutely like i said all
the choices i think are good uh the con
but there some stuff i thought was a
little too undercut by some humor
and i thought they could have
i could i thought tonally
they could have made this feel a lot
darker that are there moments that feel
dark absolutely but overall i'm like nah
man you're a zombie episode make it give
us that harrowing weight and the
desolation and the impending doom yeah
give us the desperation like yeah 28
days later just like yeah you know like
desperate times and and yeah you're
overrun by overpowered zombies not just
zombie zombies like this horrifying idea
is just super power zombies because the
personalities of everyone just felt so
light still like the personalities and
the
the way they interact felt so
light-hearted it's like i get
like i love that they gave attention to
spider-man in that moment like how are
you still able to
have this attitude i'm like well yeah it
makes sense you explained that but i'm
like what everyone else is and even like
hulk even bruce banner to a certain
extent for a lot of it seemed to lose
some of that weight or
um like scott lang you know it's uh oh
yeah he's really adjusting his head
it's conflicting because it's funny it's
amusing and it feels very paul rudd and
it feels scotland yeah it's very
animation but it isn't scott lang yeah
absolutely you know
uh so that's that's kind of the question
so
uh yeah i don't know uh yeah i i can't
definitely can't say i love this one i'm
sure if i go on social media there are
some people who are like thank you
marvel for bringing this to life and
this is the best i'm sure if i go online
i'm sure there's a lot that are saying
that keeping tears but uh personally nah
i mean i like i enjoyed it more than the
first and third episode i'll be i'll
become yeah that's a no-brainer for me
there i enjoyed it more than the first
and third episode
so but right now i would rank this as my
third
out of six
no five out of five this is number three
for me okay yeah that's about fair yeah
and the watcher nowhere no we're close
to
interference
available
see dr strange i told you so
now your cape has been on every other
here that's the thing too is like they
have the avengers show up at first i'm
like what a great opportunity to show
like the oh [ __ ] stakes of like
the zombie if if it was just the heroes
and regular people zombies i'm like yeah
they should be light because it's just
zombies but if it's like a bunch of any
hero or
x-gene or or inhuman person is out there
it's like that's a threat that's a huge
threat you know i thought they missed
the tone here and the mood
uh that's something that i thought they
kind of failed to hit the mark on
but it's still fun
yeah i mean that innocence your way you
know that's not i'm not saying that in a
passing way it's it's just in a sincere
way yeah
but guys what'd you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
is it your favorite
why are we wrong
sure why not
what if greg and john love this what
would we say
let's go what would our review be if we
would our review be
um
thanks for being here all i can do is be
honest and uh yeah that's how i felt
doctor strange episode still the best
one it is the guys subscribe click that
notification bell hit that like button
and uh let's do a page
tyler hague tyler my man
listen dude
dude tyler dude dude i feel like you
would easily survive a zombie apocalypse
undoubtably we've seen your setup at
home you got four tvs running at once
all the time you seem like you got a
spacious comfy home
you strike me as a kind of guy who would
just be chilling at home when the zombie
apocalypse is going on you wouldn't even
be aware there's a zombie apocalypse
going a few weeks at least i think you
would survive it just by letting time
pass by
all the zombies will have died out long
before you realize what's happening and
that's like the greatest benefit you can
have man you're just such a chill
relaxed
gentlemen
that you would survive simply by doing
nothing
it would be amazing yeah man it's the
winnie the pooh method it's perfect
you're just so good natured that somehow
the forces of the universe just let you
skate on by and you're so likable that i
think if zombies ended up catching up to
your doorstep
they wouldn't even try to eat you you'd
be like we can't do this again sorry
guys he's too sweet
he's too sweet of a human being who
don't you like ah he didn't even tell us
that you passed the zombie test we'll go
eat someone else so tyler thank you for
being you man you're a wonderful human
being and hey thank you for being here
for so long thanks tyler we'll talk with
you soon but be well
[Music]